gail asper vide à classer un gros de ce
qu'est ce que c'est ce qu'est ce que
c'est ça c'est une urne
ça concerne donc les votes calais vote à
l'instance savoie et municipales qu'est
ce que je peux vous dévoiler sur les
votes que je n'ai encore jamais dévoiler
partiellement que les votes étaient
truquées par ace alors un truc et non un
truc qui s'est arrêtée peut-être au
moment propice
oui alors la prod alors il ya plusieurs
choses rappelez-vous dans l'est dans les
nominations alors rappelez vous au début
on appelle les gens à vous éliminer
puis le sait ça nous a demandé à
l'époque de taper les gens avoue que ça
il me semble que les que les nominations
étaient mixtes ils pouvaient se
retrouver un garçon ou une fille c'était
40 des garçons garde des garçons et
filles de l'autre est en fait alors les
votes à l'époque c'était considérable
c'était 2 3 4 5 millions de votes par
semaine pour la finale il ya eu 3 9
millions de votes que c'était énorme
croix là mais il y avait un contrôle
d'huissier du cisci avec contrôler la
validité des des votes mais on avait
latitude pour la fermeture de vote
autrement dit si un candidat était bien
placé que ce candidat ne paraissait
voilà on pouvait arrêter un peu avant
d'en claquer truc alors sur notre saison
sur votre saison au jeu de mémoire ça
n'est pas arrivé je vous dis en saison 2
j'ai vécu un truc de fou c'est que donc
je fais je fais mon appel au vote il est
21h15 et lison et une loi et non une
enquête et un copain m'appelle je vais
je lance la pub et il me dit les votes
sont fermées ce qui se raconte et
méchant mais comment ces animaux qui
n'ont pas fermé puisque est en fait
comment vous voulez absolument sauver un
candidat
on a fermé les votes à 21h15 la
candidate a donc été sauvés sauf qu'au
lieu de mettre un disque cher mesdames
messieurs c'est un trop gros trop trop
bon nombre d'appels rappelé ben non ils
voient qu'ils ont mis les votes sont
fermés et c'est passé très bien l'époque
ça n'a pas du tout été ébruitée mais
c'était une façon il y avait une autre
façon ont tenté d'influencer c'est à
dire quelque chose de malhonnête
dans une zone appelée quand même bossé
land art j'ai plus on en a plus on leur
disait aujourd'hui une lily rush est
attaquable à l'aller n'ont atteint 418
et les votes sont faits dit non mais
suite à cette aventure là après lussier
contrôle et l'ouverture des bottes et la
fermeture des votes
évidemment mais moi j'avais comme
consigne évidemment d'essayer
d'influencer un petit peu le voter vous
voyez qu'on sait les gagnants si les
votes avaient été bien content rhône et
comment si les votes avaient été bien
contrôler correctement contrôlés ou
gérer oui les gagnants en finale
n'aurait pas été c'est gagnant alors
honnêtement dans votre saison il y avait
en fait un tel un tel engouement il y
avait tellement de vote
et quand bien même on essayait de
candidats sauf s'envoler c'était
impossible de le faire attraper
will 9 millions de votes vous pouvez
dire ce que vous voulez télévision cela
ça ne changeait pas grand chose après
oui après ça a été plus c'était plus
malléable voilà